The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good afternoon.
Usually, my first
question is do you
have any questions
about the last lecture?
We did this fly over
over 100 equations
to go from first principles to
the [INAUDIBLE] Hamiltonian.
I've put up here for you
the overview of this course.
I won't go through it again.
But I want to sort of make
you aware that we started
with the fundamental Hamiltonian
for light atom interactions.
But now we take a step back.
In the next few lectures,
we simply talk about light.
We talk about photons.
We talk about the quantum
nature of photons.
And then, after understanding
photons in more depth,
we come back and look at
more depths at atom photon
interactions.
Let me just give you a pictorial
summary of what I've just said.
AMO physics is about
atoms and photons.
And in a cartoon like
way, I can symbolize atoms
by two level systems.
Or sometimes, we have
a two level system
which is coupled by
tunneling that's also
equivalent to a
two level system.
And then we have photons,
two state systems.
And photons are different.
Photons are not
two state systems.
They are actually
harmonic oscillators.
Usually, electromagnetic waves.
But Hamiltonians
for photons can be
and have been
realized by replacing
the harmonic oscillator with
the photon with vibrations,
for example, of
ions in an ion trap
or micromechanical oscillators.
So cartoon picture again
is photons in a cavity.
But this is just another
harmonic oscillator.
So we have the atoms.
And most of what you
should know about atoms
has been discussed in 8.421.
For those of you who will
take 8.421 next year,
we'll have a lot of fun talking
about the structure of atoms.
Photons, well, I
would hope a lot
of it, at least the
harmonic oscillator aspects,
you took in 8.05 or in 8.321.
And actually, starting
today in this unit,
we want to talk about
the quantum age of light.
So you can say 8.421, we had
a deep look at the atoms.
We have now look at the photons.
But eventually, what is very
important is the interactions
between the atoms
and the photons.
That's not all.
This is sort of a very
well defined system.
A two level system and one mode
of the harmonic oscillator.
But it will become
very important--
and that's what we'll
do in a few weeks--
to discuss what happens
when this system-,
the system above
the dotted line,
becomes an open system and we
interact with the reservoir.
The reservoir will be
relevant for relaxation.
Atoms can decohere, can
lose their decoherence.
Photons will decay or decohere.
Entanglement will get lost.
And this phenomenon
of relaxation
requires the formalism
of the master equation.
And we will find
the master equation
in the form of the
optical block equation.
If you want me to add in cartoon
picture of the reservoir,
I would add many, many
harmonic oscillators.
So reservoir is characterized
by having many modes
and having a capacity
to absorb energy
without changing its state.
So this is another kind
of illustrated summary
of what we will be doing
in the next few weeks.
And today, we want to talk about
the quantum nature of light.
We're actually talking
mainly about already
a very special form
of light, namely
monochromatic light
in a single mode
of the harmonic oscillator.
And there is still a
lot to be discussed
about the statistics,
about squeezed states,
about coherent states.
We want to understand how
the quantum state of light
is modified, is
transformed, by propagation,
or how it's modified when
the light runs through a beam
splitter.
And all of this is
already relevant for just
a single mode.
And then very soon, we'll also
talk about two modes of light.
Because we need two
modes if we want
to talk about
entanglement of two modes.
I hope you will realize
in this discussion
that the quantum
nature of light is more
than light is a wave in the
form of electromagnetic wave,
or light is a particle
in the form of photons.
Things go much, much deeper.
So the unit on quantum
light will actually
evolve in six stages.
Today, we will be talking
about photons and statistics,
fluctuation, coherent states.
On next week, on
Monday, we want to talk
about non-classical
light, states
which have no classical
analogy in squeezed states.
Eventually, we want to
focus on single photons.
We will then talk about
entangled photons.
The fifth part is on
interferometry, or more
generally on metrology.
We will talk about
the short noise
limit and the
fundamental Heisenberg
limit of performing
quantum measurements.
And the last one is now opening
up the light to interactions
with atoms.
So we will talk
about interaction
of one photon and one atom
in this specific situation
of cavity QED.
So this is an overview over
the next, I don't know,
three, four, five, six lectures.
Today, we start with a
very, very short review
of the simple harmonic
oscillator, just
to set the stage.
I then want to show you
that in three minutes,
I can discuss thermal
light and the Planck Law
by just writing down
one or two equations
in the formalism we have chosen.
So we cover thermal states.
When we do laser
physics, when we
have light atom in the action,
we always need coherent states.
And we talk about
quasi-probability
distributions.
We then want to understand
fluctuations, noise,
and second order
correlation functions.
Probably this will spill
over into the next class.
We want to address
some properties
of the single photon.
Which, as you will see,
it seems a simple system,
but it is the most non-classical
system you can have,
a single photon.
But we'll come to that.
Let's start with very,
very short review
of the simple
harmonic oscillator.
It just also connects me
with the last lecture.
So how do we describe
light in a single mode?
And single mode means it
is perfectly monochromatic.
Well, we know that--
and that's what
we did last class-- that
we have the Hamiltonian
for the electromagnetic
field, which is the quantum
version of the electromagnetic
energy, B square E square.
And from that, we derived
the quantized Hamiltonian.
We introduced, just as a
reminder, vector potentials,
normal modes, and the
normal mode operators
became the a daggers.
And in second quantization,
this is the Hamiltonian
for light, which is of
course the Hamiltonian
for harmonic oscillator.
What I need today is I have
to rewrite the harmonic
oscillator.
And we have to look
at two variables--
the momentum and the precision.
Actually, the
momentum will later,
I will show you
that the momentum
of this harmonic
oscillator is actually
the operator of
the electric field.
So we need that in a second.
And of course, I assume you
know from your knowledge
of the harmonic oscillator
that precision and momentum are
linear combinations, symmetric
and anti-symmetric, of a dagger
a.
And the unit is the
prefactor square root
of h bar omega over 2.
Or here it is h
bar over 2 omega.
And of course, in precision
and momentum operators,
the Hamiltonian is
simply p square,
should remind you
of kinetic energy.
Omega square, Q square should
remind you of potential energy.
When we discuss light, we want
to discuss the electric field.
I had shown you in
one of those 100
equations the operator
for the electric field.
The operator for
the electric field
was, of course, related
to the vector potential.
And the vector potential, which
is a normal mode expansion.
And then we put
everything backward.
And we found that the electric
field operator can actually
be written.
Have to fill in a few
things, but essentially,
it's a minus a dagger.
And a minus a dagger
is nothing else
than the momentum of
the harmonic oscillator.
So here, the momentum
has a special role,
because it is the operator
of the electric field.
If you have light
in a single mode,
it has a harmonic
oscillator representation.
And the operator for
the electric field
is-- I put in a few bells
and whistles in a moment--
but is in essence
the momentum operator
of the mechanical and
analogous harmonic oscillator.
OK but the electric
field has a polarization.
We need that.
We have the photon energy
and the quantization volume.
So what I'm writing
down here is actually
the electric field,
this square root,
is the electric field
strings of a single photon
in the quantized
volume of our cavity.
So v is the quantization volume.
Then if you have a single mode
of the electromagnetic field,
well, in contrast to
a harmonic oscillator,
we have a prorogation
kr plus omega t.
And here we have
e to the minus i.
I hope I get the
signs wrong here.
Minus omega t.
But, OK, we will
mainly be looking
at an atom at the origin.
That's what we did in
the dipole approximation.
So when I said that the electric
field operator corresponds
to the momentum, I have to add
now that it is at t equals 0
and at r equals 0.
We'll come back to
that in a few moments.
OK, since I've given
you the operator--
let me just put the
operator symbol on it--
the operator of
the electric field,
I have to say now one word
about Heisenberg operators
versus Schrodinger operators.
I assume you're all
familiar with the two
different representations
of quantum mechanics.
We often use the
Schrodinger representation
where the operators
are time independent.
But in the Heisenberg
representation,
the wave function, the state
vector, is time independent.
And the time dependence of the
evolution of the quantum system
leads to a time dependence
of the operator.
So what I've written
down for you here
is actually the
Heisenberg operator,
because it has a
time revolution.
But for a single mode,
monochromatic electromagnetic
field, the time evolution
is just e to the i omega t.
So if you want to obtain
the Schrodinger operator,
you have to eliminate
the time dependence
by setting t equals 0.
At t equals 0, by definition,
the Schrodinger operator
and the Heisenberg
operator are the same.
But then, in the
Schrodinger picture,
the quantum state evolves
and the operator stays put.
In the Heisenberg picture, the
quantum state stays constant
and the operator evolves.
So I'm usually
writing down for you
expressions for
Heisenberg operators.
And if you simply set t
equals 0 in this expression,
you have the
Schrodinger operator.
Questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What happens when
there's a factor of two that
shows up in the electric
field of a single photon,
like the [INAUDIBLE]?
I thought it was
like-- [INAUDIBLE] it's
just a factor of
two [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, you have to be
careful with factors of two.
I think I got it right here.
There is no extra factor of two.
But the question is, OK,
whenever you write down
equations for the
electric field,
you want to sort of use a
and a daggers photon number,
or create photon numbers,
so they are dimensionless.
So you always need
a prefactor, which
has a dimension of
the electric field.
And for the quantisation of
light, you have two choices.
One is I can take the
electric field associated
with the single photon.
That's one option.
The other option is
I take as a prefactor
the electric field in the
ground state, which you can say
is the zero point fluctuations
of the electric field
and the two differ
by a factor of two,
because the energy
of the vacuum field
is 1/2 h bar omega, whereas 1
[INAUDIBLE] equals h bar omega.
So that's one reason why you may
sometimes find factors of two
in some textbooks
or not in others.
But I think-- I checked.
I think, as far as I
know, it is consistent.
AUDIENCE: So these operators
you've written down for e,
this is the Heisenberg operator
with the time frames right now?
PROFESSOR: This is the
Heisenberg operator
for the electric field.
But it differs.
I mean, at that point, don't--
there's nothing really to worry
about or get concerned about.
The question is, for
monochromatic light,
do we put the e to the i omega t
into the state or the operator?
It's really just
an e to the i omega
t factor has to be put either on
this state or on the operator.
These are the two choices.
Actually, my advice
to you is don't even
develop an intuitive
conceptual understanding.
And whether you are
in the Schrodinger,
try to sort of see the
structure of the operator.
I sometimes like the omega
t, because it shows you
how the electric field evolves.
And you see that explicitly.
But in the end, it's only
when you do real calculation
that you have to think hard, OK,
which picture am I using now?
Which representation
am I using now?
I'm probably not 100%
rigorous in this course
when I write down quantum states
and operators, whether I'm
always in the
Schrodinger picture
or in the Heisenberg picture.
But by simply looking, does
it have a time dependence?
Yes.
It's a Heisenberg picture.
If I write down a quantum state,
which has a time dependence,
then I've chosen the
Schrodinger representation.
It's as easy as that.
There was other?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: There's a
sign wrong up there,
because both a and a dagger
goes into the i omega
t as you have written down.
So they should be kind
of rotating right.
PROFESSOR: Give me one second.
Actually, I just wanted to say
I was careful with my notes,
but I didn't carefully
look at my notes.
This is what I have in my notes.
Does that satisfy you?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK, good.
OK so we want to talk about
quantum states of light.
The simplest eigenstates
are, of course,
the harmonic
oscillator eigenstates.
But, as I've already
mentioned, and we'll
elaborate on it further,
these are actually
non-classical states.
So quite often, we
don't want those states.
We want coherent states.
But we need those number states
said as one representation.
So let me just introduce them.
So we'll label by n the
states with n photons.
And the energy of those states
is n plus 1/2 h bar omega.
The states are normalized.
Sometimes, out of laziness,
because it doesn't matter,
we can eliminate the 1/2.
It just makes some
equations more compact.
And if I do that, I can write
the Hamiltonian like this.
You are familiar, of
course, with commutators
of a and a daggers.
And the only non-trivial matrix
element of a and a dagger
that it raises and lowers
the photon number by one.
OK, this was a short review of
the simple harmonic oscillator
as it applies to a single mode
of the electromagnetic field.
Now, just as a short
example, in subsection two,
we want to discuss
the thermal state.
And the thermal
state is nothing else
than photons in a
black body cavity.
We have a photon field,
which is in equilibrium
at temperature t.
So if you use the
canonical ensemble,
our statistical
operator is given
by this well known expression.
And if I use-- I
mean that's all.
I mean, isn't it
wonderful once you're
trained in
statistical mechanics?
This is all you have to know
about a thermal state of light?
That's it.
This is the Planck Law.
All we have to do is
take the Hamiltonian,
which we have written
down, upstairs.
So this is e to the
minus n photons.
n times h bar omega
is the energy over kt
divided by the
partition function.
This is the density matrix,
a statistical operator
for single mode light
at thermal equilibrium.
The partition function
is very simple,
because this sum over
Boltzmann factors this
is a geometric series,
which can be simply
summed up in this
way-- divided by kt.
So therefore, this
expression here
can be written as-- the density
matrix in thermal equilibrium
can be written in
the number bases.
And it's diagonal.
And the prefactor
is the probability
to have n photons populated
in thermal equilibrium.
And the probability for
n photons is given here.
We've evaluated the
partition function.
So then if you put it
together, we simply
get this-- you can call it
Boltz-Einesten factor, which
tells us what is the
probability to find
an harmonic oscillator
with n [INAUDIBLE].
And this is the expression--
e to the minus h bar omega.
So this result takes
care of many situations--
actually, almost
all situations--
you find in every
day life unless you
switch on a laser pointer.
So this describes--
and resistive filament.
It describes the light
generated by gas discharges.
It describes the
light of the sun.
And this kind of thermal
light, because it
has the-- I mean, light
in thermal equilibrium
maximizing the entropy under
the given boundary condition,
it's also called chaotic light.
It's just another name
for thermal light.
Well, we should now lean
back and take the attitude,
if I know the statistical
operator of an ensemble,
I know everything about it.
And every quantity
I'm interested in
can be calculated.
So just as an
example, we know what
is a probability
to find n photons.
But now we want to ask
what is the energy density,
or what is the mean
excitation number.
What is the average of n?
So for that, we have to take
the number operator, a dagger a,
and perform the trace
with the product
of the statistical operator.
And this is, of course,
nothing else when
we look for the probability
to find n photons.
And this probability
is weighted with n.
And what we get is the
very simple result.
It's a Bose-Einstein
distribution law
with a chemical
potential of 0, which
is the familiar distribution.
We can now use the quantity n to
rewrite our previous expression
for the probability to find n
photons in thermal equilibrium.
It is n bar to the
power n divided
by 1 over n bar times n plus 1.
So all this should be
very familiar to you.
And I'm not doing
the final step,
but I could immediately
get Planck's Law now.
All I have to use it sum up now.
This is a single mode of light,
single monochromatic light.
All I have to do is
to get Planck's law is
to sum overall modes using
the density of modes.
Any question?
We will not be talking
a lot in this course
about chaotic and
thermal light, because we
are mainly interested
in the purer form
how atom interacts with light.
And this will be when light
is in a more specific state,
not in a thermal ensemble,
in a more specific state
which are number states
or coherent states.
But nevertheless, I
feel if I don't tell you
a little bit about
ordinary light,
you will not be able to
appreciate quantum light.
So I want to use this example
now of a thermal distribution
of light and write down for
you in the next 90 seconds
expressions for
the fluctuations.
So you should know a
little bit about what
is the statistic
of thermal light.
If you find n photons in a
black cavity and you look again,
it's the standard deviation of
the photon number square root.
And is it Poissonian,
or is it much larger?
So you should know about
that, because it will then
make a difference when
we talk about the purer
states of light, coherent
states, and number
states, squeeze
states, and all that.
OK, so we want to look
now at fluctuations.
Let me just first mention that
we have normalized correctly
the probabilities.
Just one second.
What we are interested
now is the fluctuations.
So we want to know the variance.
We want to know what
is delta n squared.
And delta n squared
is of course n
square average minus
n average squared.
And we want to find out what
is that for thermal light,
for chaotic light.
So what we need now is
we need an expression.
We have already an expression
up there for n average.
And now we need an expression
for n square average.
We can get that as follows.
If we take the probability,
multiply it with n-- n minus 1.
Sum over.
So I have a brain cramp.
This equation is in my notes,
but I don't-- maybe step back--
I don't see where it comes from.
But from this
expression, of course,
we have now an expression
for n average squared.
n squared-- the sum over it.
Just a second.
n average-- n thermal--
n average squared.
Anyway, I don't want
to waste class time.
It made sense to me
when I wrote the notes.
I just can't reproduce
the argument.
So this should be obvious.
It's not obvious
to me right now.
But let's just take
it and run with it.
The left hand side
is n square minus n
multiplied with the probability.
So let me just take a note.
I will show you where
it comes from on Monday.
But assuming that
it's true, and I
know it is true, that
actually contains
n square average minus n
average is 2n average squared.
So therefore, we have
now our expression
for the average
of n square, which
is 2n average squared
plus n average.
And therefore, for thermal
light, for chaotic light,
the variance, delta n
square, is n average square
plus n average.
So the question is if
this is our variance--
the variance of thermal light,
of chaotic light, is that.
What you should
see immediately is
that it is much more fluctuating
then Poissonian statistics.
Well, if you compare now
with Poissonian statistics,
Poissonian statistics
would have fluctuations
where, well, the RMS
fluctuations are square root n.
The variance is just n average.
So thermal light is
super Poissonian,
has much, much stronger
fluctuations than Poissonian
distribution.
OK, one question for you.
If you look at the distribution
of photons-- and we
have written it down here.
Let me just scroll up.
Well, you probably don't
have an auto-plot function
in your brain.
But if you plot this
function, and I'm
asking you what is the
most probable photon number
you will find for light
in thermal equilibrium?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
PROFESSOR: Zero.
It is a broad Gaussian
centered at zero.
So you have a broad Gaussian.
The average photon
number is related
to the width of the Gaussian.
But the nature of
thermal light is
that whenever you look
into a black body cavity
and ask, what is the
most probable photon
number for any mode,
it is actually zero.
No matter how hot the
cavity is and how many
photons you have in it, the
photon number distribution
is always a broad Gaussian
with a maximum at zero.
We'll come back
to that later When
we talk about coherent states.
Then you will appreciate
the difference.
But I will be referring back
to the result we have just
derived for the photon
number distribution.
Let me just take a note.
The most probably
n is n equals 0.
OK, I hope with that-- and this
is III, the third subsection--
you can really appreciate the
properties of coherent states.
Coherent states were introduced
by Roy Glauber in 1963.
It's actually something
you should wonder about.
Coherent states seem so natural.
I mean, we teach
it in all courses.
And when we think about
harmonic oscillator,
we often think in terms
of coherent states.
But they were not
immediately used
and invented when
quantum mechanics
was invented in the '30s.
It really took somebody
like Roy Glauber
to invent coherent states.
And that happened in the '60s.
Maybe the reason why
people didn't immediately
jump at coherent states is
because coherent states are not
eigenstates of an Hamiltonian.
The definition of
a coherent state
is actually an eigenstate,
not of an Hamiltonian.
It's an eigenstate of the
annihilation operator.
And of course, the annihilation
operator is non-Hermitian.
So it's a strange operator
to look for eigenstates.
But this is what defines
the coherent state,
namely that e acting on
a coherent state alpha
equals alpha times alpha.
I'm using here the
standard notation
that alpha is both the
label for the coherent state
written down here, and
is also the eigenvalue
of the coherent
state when acted upon
with the annihilation operator.
We normalize those states.
And since we're talking
about eigenvalues
of a non-Hermitian
operator, alpha
can be any complex number.
OK, so now we have introduced
a second set of basis functions
for light.
Remember, we had the basis
functions n, the eigenfunctions
of the harmonic
oscillator, and now we've
defined a new set
of eigenfunctions,
the coherent state alphas.
Of course, the next
obvious question
is how are the two
representations connected?
So what we want to do now
is we want to figure out
how do we write a coherent
state alpha in the n basis
in the basis of eigenfunctions
of the harmonic oscillator?
So we want to write--
this is just--
want to expand the coherent
state into eigenfunctions n.
So the coefficients
we want to calculate
are those matrix elements
which are defined as cn.
So what we have
to use is in order
to find this
representation, we have
to use the fact that alpha is an
eigenstate of the annihilation
operator.
So we know that this
is alpha times alpha.
But we can also let the
annihilation operator a,
we can let the annihilation
operator a act on this state
and in this sum.
And the annihilation
operator, of course,
does what it is supposed to do.
It lowers the photon
number by one.
And we get the matrix
element square root n.
And then by just changing
the summation index by one,
we can write it as n times cn
plus 1 times the square root
of n plus 1.
So this is when the annihilation
operator acts on the sum.
And now, I'll continue
with the lower
line, which is alpha cn times n.
So what I've found now
is I've found two ways
to hide the same state,
namely a acting on alpha.
And therefore,
those coefficients
have to be the same.
And what I just
indicated in blue
is a recursion relation, which
expresses cn plus 1 by cn.
So every time you go
from cn to cn plus 1,
you multiply with the
square root of n plus 1.
So if you stare at
it for a moment,
you find that cn
is related to c0.
Yes, cn plus 1 by alpha
n over n factorial.
So of course, we get
only the relation
between the coefficients.
But if you throw in that we
want to normalize the state,
this determines c0.
And then, we get
as a final result
the normalized representation
of the coherent state
in terms of number states.
Excuse me, I think the
square root is missing here,
because it appears here times n.
OK, so what we have
found here is now
how coherent states are written
down in the number state basis.
So now we know coherent states.
And we can ask a
number of questions.
So what is this?
So what did we define?
And what have we now derived?
Let's look at some
of the properties.
The first one is that if
you look at this expression,
this is the amplitude
that will have
n photons in a coherent state.
The square of the amplitude
is the probability.
So the probability
to find n photons
is the square of
the amplitude above.
So this is that.
And this is now a
Poissonian distribution.
So it's immediately clear
that those coherent states
have much, much smaller
fluctuations in the photon
number than the thermal
state we discussed before.
Because this is Poissonian,
whereas the thermal state
had a variance which was much,
much larger than Poissonian.
OK, that's number one.
Number two is we would like to
know what is the photon number.
So we want to know what is
the expectation value for n.
That's actually
very easy to find.
You could, of course, get
the average number of photons
in by evaluating the expansion
of the coherent state in terms
of number states.
But sometimes, you should also
try to maybe directly evaluate
the coherent state.
And the photon number
operator is a dagger a.
And now you see
here we are lucky,
because a acting on alpha
is just getting alpha.
But a dagger acting on
alpha on the left hand side
gives us alpha star,
the complex conjugate.
So what we obtain here is
simply the absolute value
of alpha square.
And this is our expression
for the average photon number.
I have already mentioned
that the variance must
be-- the variance must be
n, because it's a Poissonian
distribution.
But since it is so nice to
have creation annihilation
operators acting
on coherent states,
let's just calculate--
let's verify
that this distribution--
we know that distribution
is Poissonian, but
let's verify directly
that the variance of the photon
number in the coherent state
is n, is Poissonian.
If you need the variance,
we need an average.
And we need n square average.
Let's just calculate
n square average.
So we need now the
operator for n square,
which is a dagger a, a dagger a.
We know already if
those two operators
act on the [INAUDIBLE],
that this just
gives us alpha star alpha.
And then we are left
with a a dagger.
Now, a dagger acts on alpha.
We don't know what a
dagger is acting on alpha.
We know that alpha is an
eigenstate of a, but not
of a dagger.
So therefore, we want to change
the order of a and a dagger,
use a commutator.
And then of course, a
dagger can act here.
A can act here.
And we just get another
factor of alpha.
So therefore, in a very
straightforward way,
we find now that
n square is alpha
square times alpha
square plus 1.
And using the result for
the mean photon number,
this is nothing else
than n bar, 1 plus n bar.
So if we now put it together,
we want to know the variance.
The variance is n square
average, which we've just
calculated, minus
n average squared.
And hooray, we find n bar.
And we verify again that the
fluctuations are Poissonian.
What else can we ask?
We've asked about the
statistics of fluctuation.
probability to find photons.
Well, what else do you
want to know about light?
Electric field.
Oh, that's something
I forgot to ask.
I will come back to that later.
But just sort of
to connect it, what
is the average electric
field for thermal light?
Zero.
And what else can it be?
Because any value of
the electric field,
whether the electric field
is positive or negative,
requires that the--
I say it loosely--
that the photon has a phase.
The phase will define whether
it's positive or negative.
But all different phases of the
photon field, all different--
what I mean now is
coherent states,
but have different phases--
they are all degenerate.
So in a thermal ensemble,
the states are only
populated due to
their energy, they're
populated by Boltzmann factors.
And therefore, there
is no distinction
what the phase of the state are.
So therefore, we haven't defined
yet what the phase of a photon
is, so therefore I'm a little
bit guarded with my language.
But in other words, whatever
the state with the phase
is in a thermal ensemble, you
have all phases simultaneously.
And therefore, you never have
an expectation value of e.
But of course, we had an
average number of photons.
And that means we have an
expectation value of e square,
because the expectation
value of e square
is the expectation
value of the energy.
The state has energy.
But it doesn't have
an expectation value
for the electric field.
OK, so maybe with
that motivation,
we want to figure out now does
this coherent state, which
we have constructed,
does that have now
an expectation value
for the electric field?
So there is one
thing you of course
know about this electric field.
Whenever we have
an electric field,
it needs an amplitude
and a phase.
And what I just mentioned to you
is that in a thermal ensemble,
we were just looking at the
partition function and such.
We didn't even mention a phase.
There was not any complex
number in any of the equations
we wrote down about
thermal light.
No complex number, no phase,
means no electric field.
But this is different now
for the coherent state.
Because I mentioned that alpha
in general can be complex,
the annihilation operator
can have complex eigenvalues.
So therefore, in
the coherent state--
because it is characterized
by a complex number--
we have now the possibility
to include a phase.
And what I want to show you
is, in the next few minutes,
is that yes indeed,
the coherent state
has an expectation value
of the electric field.
Instead of simply using the
equation for the electric field
operator-- remember electric
field operator was a minus
a dagger-- I want to
introduce something else which
will turn out to be
very, very useful.
And one of the application
of this concept
is to show you what
the electric field is.
This is sort of a
visual representation,
a visual representation
of the states
of the electromagnetic field.
So I want to sort of give you,
in a two dimensional diagram,
a visual representation
of thermal states,
coherent states, number states.
And this visual
representation will
make it immediately obvious
what the electric field is.
So the visual
representation will
represent what are called
quasi-probabilities.
So I have to define for you
now those quasi-probabilities.
So I denote the
quasi-probability by Q.
And I want to know what
is the quasi-probability Q
for any statistical operator
which describes a light.
It could be the operator
for thermal light.
It could be statistical operator
also includes, of course,
pure states.
And the pure state could
be a coherence state.
So this is a way to define
our quasi-probabilities
for any statistical operator
which is describing the light.
And at the quasi-probabilities,
well, the probability for what?
Well, the probabilities
for alpha.
And alpha is related
to the coherent state.
So in other words, we say
a statistical operator
has a quasi-probability with a
coherent state alpha by simply
calculating this
diagonal matrix element
of the statistical
operator with alpha.
Well, that's an abstract
definition, but it's exact.
What we should now do is I
want to show you some examples.
And then you will actually
see that it's actually
a wonderful definition.
So my first example
is let's look
at the quasi-probability
for the vacuum state.
So if the statistical
operator is simply
the ground state of the
harmonic oscillator,
no photon, no nothing,
just empty vacuum.
So the quasi-probability
for the statistical operator
is now a pure state.
So I can say, what is a
quasi-probability of the vacuum
state to be in state alpha?
Well, following the
definition above,
it's nothing else than the
matrix element, the overlap,
between the vacuum and
the coherent state alpha.
I've given you a path,
the representation
of the coherent state alpha
in terms of number states.
And all you have
to do is look now
upstairs, what is the amplitude
that this representation
includes a vacuum state.
So it's just read
of the amplitude c0
from the state above.
And this was simply e to
the minus alpha squared.
So therefore, if I--
those quasi-probabilities
can be plotted in a
two dimensional plane,
because it's a
function of alpha.
So if I use the real part
of alpha, the imaginary part
of alpha, now I can plot
the quasi-probability Q.
And since it's hard for me to
do a 3-D plot on the tablet,
I just sort of shade the region.
Black means the
amplitude is large.
And now it's sort of here.
It means the
amplitude falls off.
So what I'm plotting
here is a Gaussian,
a Gaussian with the
widths of [INAUDIBLE]
with the width of 1/2.
I think in the standard
deviation of the Gaussian,
you have a factor of 2.
Anyway, it's on the order
of-- the Gaussian width
on the order of
[INAUDIBLE] here,
I think it's 1
over square root 2,
or whatever the definition
of the standard deviation is.
So here we have a Gaussian.
Any question?
So for pure state,
we're simply asking
what is the amplitude
of the purse state
to overlap to be in
a coherent state.
And what we are
plotting is nothing
else than the probability
that this state
is a coherent state
with value alpha.
You had a question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The next
example, and we have already
prepared for that,
is the thermal state.
Example number two
So we want to know what
is the quasi-probability
for the thermal state
as a function of alpha.
The statistical operator for the
thermal states, we had derived
[INAUDIBLE] was the
probability to find n photons.
And in the number
representation,
the statistical
operator is diagonal.
And then the quasi-probabilities
are nothing else,
following the definition above,
then those probabilities times
the matrix element, the
overlap between alpha and n.
And if you look up what we had
derived for the probability pn,
you find a very simple result.
What we obtain is
again a Gaussian.
It is also centered
at the origin.
So therefore, since I
didn't label my axis,
it looks exactly
as a vacuum state.
It's just that the Gaussian
is much, much broader.
And I will come to that,
but an intuitive reading
of this Gaussian is,
well, this Gaussian
has a peak at the origin.
At the origin, this is
where alpha equals 0.
And this is directly related
to the question I asked you
before, that the photon
number probability is
peaked at n equals 0.
But I hope this will
become even clearer when
we move on to the third
example, which is now
Q of alpha of a coherent state.
Maybe just before I even
discuss the quasi-probability
of a coherent state, I have
to address one thing up front.
What would you expect
the quasi-probability
of a coherent state to be?
AUDIENCE: The
Gaussian [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Pretty good.
But I said before,
the quasi-probability
is-- let me just show
you how it was defined.
Here was my definition
of the quasi-probability.
And you can see the
quasi-probability
is the diagram matrix element
of the statistical operator
with a coherent state.
But if our statistical operator
is a coherent state, what would
you expect this
probability to be?
Just naively.
AUDIENCE: One.
PROFESSOR: One or
a delta function.
I mean, it's sort
of-- we ask, we
ask-- if you expand this
statistical operator
in coherent states,
what do we get?
But if this operator
is a coherent state,
let's say it's a coherent
state beta, you would expect,
well, then we only get
something non-vanishing if alpha
equals beta.
So you would naively
expect that what you get
is a delta function.
The coherent state beta
has a quasi-probability Q
of alpha, which
is peaked at beta.
But it's peaked as
a delta function.
Now, I'm calculating
it for you right now,
and the result is
this is not the case.
The reason is-- and
I will show that
to you-- is that the
coherent states are not
your ordinary basis function.
The coherent state forms a
basis which is over complete.
So we have sort of more
coherent states than necessary.
There is some redundancy.
And therefore, the
coherent state alpha
and the coherent state
beta, if there's only
a small difference between alpha
and beta, they have overlap.
Coherent states which
differ by only a little bit
in their eigenvalue,
they're not orthogonal.
So this is a complication.
It's one of the
complications we have
to deal with when we want
to describe coherent states
and when we want to
describe laser lights.
But this is one
of the properties.
So therefore, when
I'm now discussing
with you is what are
the quasi-probabilities
of a coherent state, it will
not be a delta function.
But we should simply
follow the definition,
and everything will
fall into place.
So our statistical operator
for a pure coherent state
is, of course-- this is
a statistical operator
with pure state beta.
And the quasi-probability
for the coherent state beta
to be an alpha is this
matrix element squared.
And you can calculate
that, for instance,
by just putting in
alpha, alpha and beta,
the expansion of alpha
and beta in number states.
So just have to solve the
integral and calculate it.
And what you find is
not a delta function,
but a decaying exponential.
So you can say, as long
as alpha and beta do not
differ by more than one,
there is substantial overlap.
So in other words, what we
get for this quasi-probability
is something which
is centered at beta.
But it is again a Gaussian.
So the important message
here is coherent states
are not orthogonal
to each other.
They form an over
complete basis.
Maybe as a side remark,
it may come as a surprise
to you, because you have been
trained too much in basis
states of emission operators,
of energy eigenstates.
And those energy eigenstates
form a complete basis.
The coherent states
are eigenfunctions
of very strange operator,
a non-emission annihilation
operator.
So therefore, the few
things you took for granted
do not apply here.
So we have our nice diagram
with-- [INAUDIBLE] diagram
for quasi-probabilities.
So now if you have-- that
was the real part of alpha.
That was the imaginary
part of alpha.
So if you take that
as a complex plane,
and I'm drawing now as a
phase of the complex number
beta, which is the eigenvalue
of the coherent state beta,
then the quasi-probability
is centered near beta.
And it's a decaying Gaussian.
I'm not showing it
in here explicitly,
but it is simply
the vacuum state
we discussed before
displaced by beta.
My fourth example,
just to show you.
So far, I've shown you that
everything is Gaussian.
Thermal light is a broad
Gaussian, coherent state
is a narrow Gaussian, the vacuum
state is a narrow Gaussian.
Let me just show
you something which
is non-Gaussian, which
is the number state.
If you put into the definition
of the quasi-probability
the number state, and you
calculate the quasi-probability
as a function of alpha, then
you find that what you get
is actually not a Gaussian.
What you get is a ring, a
ring with a certain width.
So this is the representation
of a number state.
And the radius of this ring is
proportional to the square root
of the number of photons
in a number state.
We'll come back to photon states
in much more detail very soon.
But I just wanted to show
you that at this point.
So quasi-probabilities
are not always Gaussian.
They really depict
something, they
show us something
important about-- they
show us important
differences about the quantum
states of light.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] a delta
function [INAUDIBLE] radius,
[INAUDIBLE] little
past [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Can you hold the
question for three minutes?
OK.
They quick answer is it's not.
But in three minutes,
I want to tell you
that there are three
possible definitions
of quasi-probabilities-- the
Q function, to W function,
and the P function.
In one of the functions,
it's a delta function.
In the Q function, it's not.
But we'll come to that.
But let's for now stick
to the Q function.
The next thing we want to put
in is the time dependence.
I want to show you that when we
have quantum states of light--
and right now, we've just
shown the quasi-probability
distribution at a
snapshot of t equals 0.
What happens as a
function of time?
What I want to show
you is-- and this
makes those quasi-probabilities
also nice and intuitive--
that as a function of time, the
quasi-probability distribution
simply rotates with an
angular frequency of omega.
So let me show that to you.
We know that we have
a coherent state.
And what we want
to understand is
what happens when we act on the
coherent state with the time
propagation operator,
which is the Hamiltonian
in the exponent.
Well, in order to evaluate
the left hand side,
we can simply take the
expansion of coherent states
into in a number
basis, because we
know that the time
evolution of a number state
is simply the energy
of the number state
with which it's given by
the energy of the number
state, which is n
times h bar omega.
So now if you look for a
second at this expression,
you realize that we can
absorb the time evolution
if you redefine alpha to become
alpha times e to the i omega t.
So in other words, the time
evolution of the coherent state
alpha preserves the character
as a coherent state.
It just means we get
an incoherent state
whose eigenvalue is now alpha
times e to the i omega t.
So that means the following.
If you want to look at the
time evolution in terms
of quasi-probabilities,
we have our diagram
with the real part of alpha,
with the imaginary part
of alpha.
And let's assume we had
a coherent state, which
happened-- this is
sort of now my circle.
It's, you can say,
a high contrast
representation of the Gaussian.
So this is the quasi-probability
of the initial state alpha.
But as time propagates, it
just gets multiplied with e
to the i omega t.
That means when the
time evolution is just
displacing the state over
there, and as time goes by,
the coherent state is
just moving in a circle.
And after one full
period of omega,
we are back where we started.
Now let me give you now
an intuitive picture
what the electric field is.
I will be a little bit more
exact in two or three minutes.
So we have a diagram of
the real part of alpha
and the imaginary part of alpha.
For a harmonic oscillator, I
can also label it as x and p.
You know, in
harmonic oscillator,
when you can think
about it classically,
if you have some
initial distribution
of a mechanical
oscillator in x and p,
what the system actually
does is it simply
rotates on a circle
in phase space.
The classical phase
space is x and p.
And I haven't really
told you that I
was-- I didn't want to get
lost in complex definitions.
I defined for you the
quasi-probability,
but the quasi-probability
is a generalization
of the classical
phase space function.
Phase space function is
a function of p and x.
So take my word for
a second, and allow
me to identify the real axis
with x and the imaginary axis
with p.
Well, then p is
the electric field.
So now, what you should visually
take from those pictures
is that if you want to know
what the electric field is,
you just sort of
project this fuzzy
ball on the imaginary axis.
So in other words,
when I ask you
what is now the electric field
as a function of time, at t
equals 0, I project
this onto the p axis.
And what I get is something
which is centered at 0.
But it has also a
certain fuzziness.
The fuzziness is given
by the size of the disk,
or by the width of the Gaussian.
And if I now use this picture
as a function of time,
as this fuzzy ball
rotates around,
the electric field goes
up and down in one cycle.
And the fuzziness moves with it.
So the fuzziness here for the
electric field is related--
and that's what we want
to discuss next week--
is related to short noise.
I also want to tell you
that the coherent state is,
to some extent, the
best possible way
to define an electric field.
It's a minimum
uncertainty state.
I want to show you that
the coherent state is
sort of at the minimum of
Heisenberg's Uncertainty
Relation.
So I think if you
take this picture,
you will immediately
realize that you
draw the quasi-probability, you
project on the vertical axis.
And you get the electric field
that tells you immediately
if you have a
thermal state, which
is a Gaussian centered here.
You project it.
You get an electric field 0.
It has an enormous
fuzziness, but it's 0.
And this picture that everything
rotates with angular frequency
omega also tells
you, as expected,
that in a thermal
state, it's already
a circularly symmetric
distribution.
When it rotates,
nothing changes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE],
couldn't you
find, eigenstates for
that operator itself,
and then get rid
of this fuzziness?
AUDIENCE: Could
it just be, like,
eigenstates of the
harmonic oscillator, so not
stationary at all?
PROFESSOR: I'm a little
bit confused now.
Actually, two people mind if
I teach a few minutes longer?
I can just finish the--
I want to have one,
I have one footnote.
I really want to sort
of give it to you,
because I think it
will help some of you.
Pardon?
AUDIENCE: We have a
class starting at 2:30.
PROFESSOR: There's a
class starting at 2:30?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Then I
have to wrap up.
Sorry.
Then let me just
tell you what I will
do at the beginning
of the next class.
What I've told you here
with the projection
of the electric
field, this is not
100% rigorous for the
quasi-probabilities Q.
Due to the non-commutativity
of operators,
when we generalize phase
space function into quantum
mechanics, we can order
operators in a symmetric way,
in a normal way, in
an anti- normal way.
And therefore, there are three
different quasi-probabilities.
The Q probability is
the easiest to define.
It comes in very handy.
But what I showed you
with the projection
does not rigorously apply
to the Q distribution.
It applies to the p
or w distribution.
But the difference is, unless
you really go into subtleties,
are minor.
So intuitively, what
I did is correct.
And to answer your
question, an eigenstate
of the electric field, I have a
little bit problems with that.
Because if you take this
projection, what you need
is you need something
which is very, very narrow.
But since this area is
in Heisenberg uncertainty
limited area, it means delta
x delta p equals h bar over 2.
The only way how you can
create this electric field
is you can completely
squeeze it.
So to the best of my knowledge,
an electric field eigenstate
would be a completely
strongly squeezed state.
We'll talk about that next week.
But then you realize,
if you've completed
squeezed your state
after a quarter period,
this infinitely squeezed ellipse
is now standing upside down.
And after a quarter
period your electric field
is completely uncertain.
So I think you can
define an operator,
you can find a state
which has a sharp value
of the electric field
at one moment of time.
But then it rotates around.
And what was a highly
certain electric field
becomes highly uncertain later.
OK, enough things to discuss.
We'll go on next week.